welcome to 30 playing I ender I ender
ender I don't know okay well that's a
good score seven games six and a half
points check yep going to continue
playing despite my results are not that
bad so why not keep forgetting how it is
actually played I think age 3 is right
hmm ok ok Knight f3 Queen h5 that
shouldn't be too bad g4 then I can take
what I hope I can take I guess I can G
494 yep
I mean it's not all golden for wife if
hear ya so d5 I guess or anything else
hmm also d6 of course d 5 in 5 and I
don't really believe that this is so
great for what let's see so he is going
with this oh yeah okay taking on here on
age 3 is certainly unsound hmm how to
play that funny position maybe Bishop f5
just trading some stuff and try to get
to 94 it could actually be interesting
no 94 is coming unless he takes or does
he have some kind of technical thing
that you can shoot for with them the pin
issue here going on moving the Queen
somewhere so that the night actually
hangs hmm but I'm not sure No
don't don't see it okay
yeah it's a simple and good move of
course and what now they'll probably
just just take things once here 97 maybe
a while edwin lamb and steak first
that's a simpler and the five is
attacked quite a number of times
Oh came out for Queen print sorry out
for Queen B 7 it seems
hmm it's not not so easy here actually
what now
hmm looks like he is winning one of the
pawns I wonder how to play that him yeah
maybe and shoot for activity I don't I
don't see how I can defend here defend
Ponzi anyway it's prob least after 26
still okay I mean basically blunder d5
but we need six was difficult to keep
the material here you should just play
Quincy six all that it's probably
getting to be a the same thing at the
end twin 6 p-8 Quincy seven can be too
it's it's just equal
hmm yeah it's a bit disappointing okay
so he seemed simcity tries to to do
something him okay
check check check
and while trading queens I don't know
not necessary really check check I
cannot play for win anyway unfortunately
check mm-hmm game draw gym that wasn't
very exciting but he had he had enough
play down he really had enough play with
that with that with that Queen asics
moving fairly fairly logical stuff maybe
yeah in order to play for win probably I
should do something else I mean just to
avoid the immediate trade down to
nothing no no this is this is going to
lead to add to everything getting shot
off this is what the engine is
recommending yeah this is more
interesting at least hmm yeah yeah
that's that's what I should done just to
keep the game going okay i want to
quickly check things here this is
castles and maybe the six is more
interesting i don't know actually like
like this idea but it seems good I mean
he just played it played in fine this is
getting lost now but he's just in time
with Queenie six it's just a draw it's
not much not much I can do I should have
deviated earlier around here there's
absolutely nothing to do if any of
anything then White has a better
structure but it never enough it's never
enough to win the game if black is
playing a good defense okay well thanks
for watching